i
did this five-day thing right where we
were going through it and i had this guy
and it was kind of a slog and i remember
i really didn't like doing it because
the guy was like not he was not fun yeah
also driving in london sucks yeah it's
like
it's like it's a going slow simulator
and stopping waiting giving way to
people like just it's not like driving
outside of the the london like at all
it's completely different so so i'm
doing this and uh it's not like driving
in wales definitely no yeah we get to
the fifth day i'm like
so ready to like book the test he's like
no
i was like what do you mean he's like
you're not ready yet
all right and what do you mean it's like
five days guarantee
you're gonna fail right now if you do it
and i'm like oh oh my what do we do then
he's like well
shit's back like like loves it oh yeah
yeah i'm like i'm like he's like yeah
well you know you could uh you know pay
me in cash and i'll give you uh some
private lessons you know and i was like
oh
i was like oh i was like oh i was like
is that
okay he's like yeah it's okay
according to me
and it was like conveniently like really
expensive oh wow but i was like but i
was like well [ __ ] i need him to say yes
so that i can yeah yeah you won't do it
without him so you literally bribed him
no no
yeah i can't do the lesson without him
agreeing right yeah so i was like oh and
i was like well when do we do it because
i kind of wanted to get this over and
done with i got to go to america and
like yeah i wanted to get this done he
was like oh um well you free tomorrow
and i was like yeah i'm free tomorrow
and he was like all right well meet me
in this this
car park tomorrow and we'll do like
three hours and then we'll see how you
do yeah so i pay him an extortionate
amount of money
and you know and then we do the three
hours like all right now you're ready
and i'm like yeah
yeah
of course of course you're ready now you
probably just let me drove around for
the hour so isn't illegally a bribe or
something
so um we he finally does it and uh the
way that this works normally in the uk
if you want to test i don't know how i
was in australia but you have to wait
like a month yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
but because i don't know how they do it
but this company has like an in with the
government where basically like if
anyone cancels they get all those
reservations oh so you basically have to
just be ready right and they'll be like
are you free tomorrow to do the test
yeah right so that's what happened so i
i i said i'm ready to get the test and
then like one day later they were like
come to this place at this time uh the
teacher will will be there and i was
like oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] nerve-wracking
now we have to go to like for all of our
tests you have to go to like a
government certified like road and
maritime services no we did we did it
you have to do as well
a thing yeah so so i go to this building
and it's like the the official
government building
is above a like a salon
like it's in this
really weird like beat up room it's just
one room what and like there's like
seven other people in here yeah and i
just turn up and i'm like what the [ __ ]
it's so weird right it looks like some
government building it like doesn't look
it's just above like a salon a chicken
shop
so i go in and they're like did you park
the car so there's no car park in this
place either right park on the street
right so i'm i'm parked on a hill
upwards yeah right and so i'm on like a
right before like you're a manual right
yeah manually so i'm i'm parked on a
hill right before roundabout and it's a
really busy dual carriageway yeah this
is awful right that's like nightmare
so i'm bricking it and he's and this guy
can tell i'm freaking out because it's a
horrible start yeah if you let it roll
back at all like yeah you fall down the
hill you fell immediately yeah and
normally like most driving like things
you might not even have to do this thing
you start from a hill yeah so i was like
[ __ ] i've because my instructor decided
to park here this is where i had to
start yeah so i was like [ __ ] so so you
know i'm doing it and i i i'm i'm really
[ __ ] i let go of the the break and
i'm just not moving i'm luckily
maintaining it and i slowly start to
creep and then it's [ __ ] laurie just
go down and like goes past me i'm ah i'm
freaking out like
i'm like holding on to the clutch like
not letting it go because i don't want
to go and i don't want to fall down yeah
i'm just like sweating and he's like
wait calm down mate what are you doing
just don't worry about it he's like
proper london and i was like oh yeah
thanks man i'm real calm now yeah
luckily i get going it's really easy you
know everything's going well and this
guy looks like he's falling asleep he's
literally like this
on the window yeah
i was like what the [ __ ] and i did a
thing where i thought i failed and then
i was like oh [ __ ] i was freaking out
cause i thought i failed halfway through
and i go through the
and um yeah i passed i did like one
minor mistake that was all i had don't
know how because on the way to the test
i ran a red light i did all things wrong
and everything went terribly and then um
yeah weirdly at the end of it my
instructor came with the guy is like
really weird he came over and he was
like thought he failed and i was like
why would you say that
he's like you know how i knew i thought
you failed and i was like how and he's
like you know when the guy opens the
door before he gives the news it's not a
bad sign i'm like why why why would that
be a bad sign why does that make any
sense i don't understand so he can run
away why is it like trying to like
psycho analyze it so it's not like you
got a dick at us
i actually had a really nice instructor
he was like it was like uh he was like a
proud dad he was like i knew you'd pass
but the thing is my dad was my
instructor your dad was dressed yeah
because in australia you don't when
you're on your learners you don't have
to go to lessons if you don't want no
you don't have to in the uk yeah it's
just like my parents so my parents are
like no that's [ __ ] expensive you're
not going to lessons my dad's like son
i'll teach you and i was like dad you
are literally the most crazy [ __ ]
driver i've known yeah because most
people when they drive they don't drive
like how they 100 percent should yeah
my parents wanted to teach me because
they were like we're probably not doing
some things right ourselves i was like
dad we're in an 80 zone and i'm doing a
hundred is this okay and he's like
that's where he looks like and he's like
no it's like no everyone else is doing
it they can't arrest all of us
that's true
yeah that's true that's fair enough
can i do this in the test yeah like i
said don't do it in the test but you'll
be right now driving is way more fun
when you've passed your test because
you're like okay i can kind of like
relax like oh this is like what is like
driving stressless now yeah yeah yeah
exactly i do remember the first time i
was like in the seat of a car actually
so um in the driver's seat of a car was
actually
when i was about like i think like 12 or
13. so like i remember like there was
there was one day where i think there
was like like a friend of a cousin who
was just like you know he was like very
rich so they like their family owned
like a lot of land right right a lot of
land
and so
um on some of this land that they owned
right um they let they let this kid they
let their kid uh drive around like drive
around like a drive around a car it was
it was like a beaten up car right it was
it was a beach napkin oh yeah right um
and i remember going to this place once
and i was like and he was like driving
around his field i was like dude this is
badass and he was like you want to go
want to go and i was like
am i allowed to do that am i allowed to
do that he was like yeah it's private
land it's legal it's legal and i was
like 12 year old knew the concept
and i start like [ __ ] [ __ ] myself
oh yeah because i'm because i'm just
like i'm in a [ __ ] car old choice
like a twelve-year-old
as a twelve-year-old in the seat of a
car it doesn't matter if you're like
driving a jeep or a mini it's like
[ __ ] operating a gundam like oh no it
it is terrifying it is terrifying yeah i
remember the first [ __ ] thing i did
and he he was just like oh just you know
just tap the pedal a bit right
as a 12 year old i don't know what tap
means right
and so i'm just like i go what i think
is like uh it's i i thought tapping it
was going 50 of the way down yeah you do
you do you do
so i'm like okay i'm going to tap this
i'm not going to put it all the way just
half the way like immediately we'll
start
and i immediately crashed into his gates
right oh no
luckily it's like an old wooden gate and
it's like in the middle of [ __ ] up
well like but [ __ ] nowhere right
i smash into this gate right and i i
started freaking out and he was like
all right get out of the driver's seat
never again
i like that i think that put me off
driving like for like well obviously i
was scared of the concept of driving
like like that one experience i think i
remember now yeah like the first time i
ever got into car seat was probably
around that age as well like 12 13 yeah
when we went camping yeah and like you
know because you're in a camping field
right not a lot of like and especially
when you're in a big camping field and
there's no one else there it's just a
lot of like really empty flat land so my
dad was like son
why don't you want to you want to take
it for a spin
and i was like sure dad
i get in the and i get in the seat and
in my head i'm like yeah this is going
to be easy there's literally nothing
around
except one tree
but like like any any person will tell
you it's like just don't go towards the
tree just go to this entire open area
where there was nothing
and in my head i was like okay just
don't go over to the tree what do i do
immediately go towards the tree did your
dad not like pull the wheel oh yeah he
did oh okay he was like son
oh my god dude i wouldn't be alive if i
hit the tree i think my dad would kill
me yeah my dad would 100
but like i i don't know what it was it
was like in my 12 year old stupid 12
year old head
in the entire time i was like don't go
towards the tree don't go towards the
tree my hands are like go towards trees
okay
it's like a homing missile
like target locked on